all right I'm GOP senators they have
until September the 30th to keep their
word and now kill off Obamacare or
they're gonna face consequences at the
ballot box in 2018
now senators Lindsey Graham bill Cassidy
they offered up an amendment that's
gaining momentum and Republicans in my
opinion albeit imperfect they need to
seize this opportunity now while meeting
with foreign leaders at the UN President
Trump he weighed in on this latest
attempt to end Obamacare let's take a
look 16% I think there's tremendous
support for I think it's actually much
better than the previous shot which was
very sadly but then I thought that what
I want I would go to the Oval Office
sit down on my desk and they would be
honest I'll be the first to say this is
not a perfect bill by any means but we
learned a lot about Republicans in this
process about a hundred in the house
seven in the Senate they clearly had no
intention of ever really repealing and
replacing Obamacare now the question is
can we begin the process of making
health care better for you the American
people or in the end this is what it's
going to come down to you keep Obamacare
skyrocketing premiums and deductibles
and of course lack of health care
options all around the country
it is crushing average Americans every
day so here are the big things that
Cassidy and Graham and what it does it
does replace Obama care subsidies with
block grants to States and then states
will have the flexibility to choose
how best to spend that money instead of
adhering to big government mandates I've
always believed in block grants the
massive budget-busting Medicaid
expansion that'll be scaled back
insurers they will be able to offer
finally it's illegal now catastrophic
plans that people can actually afford
Obamacare it prevents consumers from
even having that option health savings
accounts that will be expanded as well
as cooperatives now Republicans they
need to get moving they need to start
keeping their promises we on this
program we will continue to hold them
accountable until it gets done and
ultimately done right also tonight well
Hillary Clinton she is refusing to go
away the twice failed former
presidential candidate now attacking
presidents from what I thought was one
of his best speeches at the United
Nations including taking issue with his
term Rocketman the nickname for Kim
jong-un watch this I thought it was very
dark dangerous not the kind of message
that the leader of the greatest nation
in the world should be delivering we
call on all nations to work with us to
try to end the threat posed by Kim
jong-un and not call him rocket man the
old Elton John song but to say clearly
we will not tolerate any attacks on our
our friends or ourselves North Korea is
not our friend now here's the problem
the left-wing media in this country you
know what they're losing it over
President Trump in a speech just like
Hillary and will give you the history
lesson in a second watch this he wasn't
a president he was a preacher up there
given his dark world view it's difficult
to applaud to a line that parts of the
world are going to hell this was a very
somber arc speech I thought that was one
of many examples of how intellectually
confused if not outright incoherent this
speech was it's really frightening to
hear an American president talked about
obliterating any other country the
rhetoric was was was irresponsible it
was put many world leaders on edge and
frankly it was contradictory in many
many places I'd call it a simplistic
axis of evil speech on steroids
I mean one more time you know simplistic
axis of evil on steroids he's talking
about going back to the 19th century it
may play to the base but for most of the
people in the room they're gonna leave
with a lot of indigestion this was an
unusual speech for an American president
does it have any of the hallmarks of
unusual speeches by other countries
presidents is this a whisper down in the
history of weird UN speeches it is
certainly an unusual speech a weird
speech
Rocketman insulting kim jong on it
here's what's nuts they're more angry at
Donald Trump than they are at the guy
that's firing missiles over Japan on a
regular basis that has nuclear
capability that he may marry to ICBM
capability and threaten the whole world
this is we'll have more on the insane
liberal media with joke on Chad Leslie
Marshall in just a minute but first I
want to get back to Hillary and give
this little history lesson going after
President Trump Hillary has no business
criticizing anybody on foreign policy
you want to know why we're in the
situation because her and her husband
they set the stage for this dangerous
situation for the entire world with
Pyongyang because Hillary also had a
direct hand and she brokered this
idiotic nuclear deal with Iran now we
all remember what a disaster the whole
Russia reset thing was and since Clinton
liberals the mainstream destroyed Trump
media seem to have forgotten here's the
Hannity history lesson let's flashback
to 1994 that's the year Bill Clinton he
thought it was a great idea to trust a
dictator in that particular case North
Korean leader Kim jong-il who is Kim
Jong Un's father now Clinton tried to
bribe Pyongyang North Korea into
freezing and stopping the nuclear
program and he gave them four billion
dollars of your money and energy aid and
Clinton was so proud of the deal it that
he cut he even went on TV and there's a
good deal for the American people look
where we are now mister Clinton take a
look this is a good deal for the United
States North Korea will freeze and then
dismantle its nuclear program South
Korea and our other
allies will be better protected the
entire world will be safer as we slow
the spread of nuclear weapons South
Korea with support from Japan and other
nations will bear most of the cost of
providing North Korea with fuel to make
up for the nuclear energy it is losing
and they will pay for an alternative
power system for North Korea that will
allow them to produce electricity while
making it much harder for them to
produce nuclear weapons the United
States and international inspectors will
carefully monitor North Korea to make
sure it keeps its commitments only as it
does so well North Korea fully join the
community of nations a lot of good that
worked out now it's so easy to figure
out what happened next because
appeasement capitulation of dictators
despot it never works and Kim jong-il
he quickly broke his word and by the end
of the 90s North Korea began testing
missiles then in 2006 they conducted
their first nuclear test and then once
Obama got into office North Korea's
aggression increased dramatically all
while Obama was literally gutting
America's Strategic Defense capabilities
then of course we got Iran and Hillary
Clinton leading the way early on
negotiating this disastrous nuclear deal
there she paved the way for Obama to
give the radical mullahs in Iran over a
hundred billion dollars planeloads of
cash and other currencies and as
terrible as that agreement is well you
know what that may soon be coming to an
end listen what the president said
earlier today finally watch
now this comes after president Trump
ripped the deal during his speech
yesterday to the UN General Assembly
calling it an embarrassment for their
America liberals they're freaking out
that the president dared to say what he
said but let's remind the left what they
are defending the Iran nuclear deal that
deal gave Iran up to a hundred plus
billion dollars in immediate sanctions
relief the deal does not prohibit the
development of ballistic missiles Tehran
can partner with Russia on defensive
missile systems and Iran can buy
anti-aircraft missiles and after eight
years in conventional weapons after five
years and the radical mullahs will guess
what they didn't have to destroy any
nuclear related facilities zero now they
of course can also deny access to
certain nuclear sites and Iran on the
other sites they have at least 24 days
notice of an inspection and they can
pick the nuclear inspectors and they're
still allowed to spin their centrifuges
by the way those restrictions expire
after 10 years to 15 years so they're
still getting nuclear weapons see a
pattern here
Bill Clinton North Korea Hillary Clinton
Iran this is dangerous for the entire
world and they're upset about
Rocketman